en este vídeo vamos a trabajar con un
problema muy interesante dada esta tabla
de contingencia
esto es una tabla de contingencia
que nos brinda información acerca de 23
grupos de personas a las que se las
sometió a distintos tratamientos para
combatir cierta enfermedad supongamos
una gripe entonces a el primer grupo se
le sometió a un al uso de una hierba 1 y
20 se mantuvieron enfermos y 100 no se
enfermaron
la hierba 2 tuvimos 30 y 110 que nos
enfermaron y luego un tercer grupo que
se les otorgó un placebo 30 se
mantuvieron enfermos y 90 no se
enfermaron no se curaron o como quieran
verlo
para esto la idea nuestra es comprobar
queremos comprobar que las hierbas
sirven para algo realmente sirven para
curar estos estos resfríos o estas
gripes por lo tanto vamos a plantear
un test de hipótesis
que nos diga o con una hipótesis nula
que nos diga que las hierbas no hacen
efecto y una hipótesis alternativa que
sería la que nos interesa comprobar que
diga que las hierbas si hacen efecto
para eso vamos a tener un nivel de
significancia del 0 0 10 que es un 10%
del total
ahora bien nosotros ya tenemos si
estuvieron viendo los anteriores vídeos
ya tienen bastante y ya tenemos bastante
práctica con el tema esté de test de
hipótesis
nosotros sabemos muy bien que tenemos
que primero asumir asumimos la hipótesis
nula
ahora si asumimos la hipótesis no la
vamos a necesitar ciertos datos para
tratar de refutar la
entonces para seguir utilizando esta
tabla vamos a usar una columna más que
nos otorgue el total de personas que se
mantuvieron enfermas y no enfermas
entonces acá tenemos un total de 80
personas y acá tenemos 100 más 110 210
más 90 300 personas
también podríamos trabajar porque no con
el total
el total de personas que hubo en cada
grupo por lo tanto en el primer grupo
hubo 120 personas en el segundo grupo
hubo 140 y en el tercer grupo hubo otras
120 personas esto finalmente nos
determina un total de 380 personas
vamos a redondear este valor a este
valor importante es el total de personas
que se sometieron a este tratamiento
muy bien veamos también de qué otra
forma podemos expresar estas 80 y estos
300 pacientes tenemos que 80 es el 21%
y 1% y hacerlo con otro color más claro
a ver que quiero plantear 80 - / perdón
380 es igual a 0 21 es decir el 21 por
ciento de los pacientes o de los de las
personas que se sometieron a este
tratamiento se mantuvieron enfermos es
decir un 21 por ciento por lo tanto un
79 por ciento
se pudo curar o se mantuvo inmune a esta
enfermedad
así con este criterio nosotros podríamos
determinar un porcentaje para cada uno
de los de los grupos es decir el 21% de
120 es decir el 21% de 120 que es el
total de personas que estuvieron en el
grupo de la hierba 1 que sería el el 21
por ciento 120 es la cnd el porcentaje
esperado vamos a escribir esto esto
sería el el valor esperado
esperado
para los que se enfermaron y del grupo
de los que consumieron la hierba 1 esto
nos entrega un porcentaje de un
porcentaje sino un valor
de 25-3 no sé qué raro hablar de números
con decimales cuando hablamos de
personas pero vamos a utilizar estos
valores de esta forma ahora el 79% vamos
a verlo de esta forma el 79%
de 120 es decir la cantidad o el valor
esperado y el valor esperado
y hacer una división acá para no
confundir con el total el valor esperado
de personas que tendrían que haber
permanecido no enfermos del grupo de la
hierba uno es el 79% de 120 que es 94
94,7
y lo mismo vamos a hacer con todos los
grupos el 21% de 140 es igual a 29 4 y
el 79% de 140 es 110,6 el 21% de 120 es
como vimos antes el 25,3 y tenemos
también nuevamente acá 94 7 es
exactamente igual que los de la primera
columna
por lo tanto tenemos nuestro valor
esperado según lo que nos tendría que
indicar lo que lo que los porcentajes
que tenemos y tenemos el valor observado
por así decirlo que es el de las
personas que vimos enfermas y no ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es conseguir el
valor si cuadrado el valor h cuadrado
para la distancia de lo observado al spa
lo esperado como hicimos en problemas
anteriores para eso vamos a tener que
hacer
para hallar el x cuadrado el valor si
cuadrado tenemos que hacer 20 menos 25 3
al cuadrado
y esto lo dividimos por 25 3 para
expresar lo en unidades del valor
esperado es decir que estamos haciendo
estamos haciendo esta distancia o la
distancia mejor dicho la distancia que
hay de este valor a este valor
o viceversa la distancia que hay de este
valor a este otro valor
y eso lo vamos a repetir para cada una
de las celdas la distancia que hay entre
los valores esperados y los valores
observados por así decirlo
vamos a trabajar de esta forma acá
tenemos 30
- 29 4 al cuadrado sobre 29 4 más 30
- 25 3 al cuadrado sobre 25 3 a esto le
sumamos sigo acá abajo más 100
- 94 7 al cuadrado / 94 7 más
110 - 110 6 al cuadrado es decir estamos
averiguando como insisto para no dejar
prendido tantos números sin sentido que
estamos buscando la distancia del valor
observado el valor esperado en verdad y
el cuadrado de la distancia de ese valor
a esto lo dividimos por 110 6 y por
último tenemos 90 menos 90 y 47 al
cuadrado dividido 94 7 esto como
resultado al realizar toda esta extensa
operación los invito a ustedes a
realizarlas si tienen una calculadora o
si quieren practicar este tipo de
de operaciones o de cuentas esto nos da
un valor de 253 es decir que 253 es
nuestro valor crítico
valor crítico
lo que tendríamos que ver ahora es la
probabilidad de conseguir este valor
crítico y recordar que si este valor
crítico es menor a el 10% o si la
probabilidad la probabilidad de
conseguir este valor crítico es menor al
10 por ciento estaríamos rechazando la
hipótesis nula en favor de lo que
nosotros queremos comprobar
pero vamos a borrar
tenemos 2,53
este es el valor que tenemos va a ser
más sencillo
antes antes que nada lo que tenemos que
averiguar también es los grados de
libertad grados
de libertad
y vamos a hacer una especie de
comprensión lógica de dónde salen los
grados de libertad nosotros tendríamos
si tenemos seis celdas una dos tres
cuatro cinco seis celdas es lógico y es
muy sabido que tendríamos cinco grados
de libertad pero esto sería erróneo
razonar lo iban a ver porque cuando
trabajamos contra contingencia
en donde tenemos un número de filas y un
número de columnas y los grados de
libertad a serlo acá abajo vamos a
borrar esto los grados de libertad los
calculamos de una forma distinta los
grados de libertad va a ser el número
número de filas
- 1
por el número de columnas
- 1 esto sería si tenemos dos filas 2 1
por tres columnas
3 - 1 esto es igual a 1 por 2 es igual a
22 grados de libertad
grados de libertad
y esto es para las tablas de
contingencia en donde no contamos claro
están los datos totales ni los del valor
esperado es decir solo contamos los
datos que teníamos desde un principio
que eran los primeros seis datos que
teníamos
y esto también tiene cierta lógica
porque decimos que tenemos dos grados de
libertad se dice que si conocemos los
totales supongamos que ya conocíamos los
totales todos los totales todos los
valores totales
solo con dos valores con dos datos más y
usar algunos a borrar un poco todo esto
solo con dos datos más supongamos este
valor otro colo grave supongamos que
tenemos este valor y este otro valor
sólo con esos datos ya podríamos
averiguar el resto de los valores porque
porque conocemos los totales si
quisiéramos saber por ejemplo tenemos 20
y 120 si quisiéramos averiguar el valor
de los nuevos enfermos tranquilamente
hacemos el total menos los que están
enfermos y nos da el 100 quien tenemos
por lo tanto se dice que tenemos 2
grados de libertad
y ese es el motivo por el cual decimos
que tenemos k igual a 2 que son los
grados de libertad pero también dijimos
que teníamos un alfa del 10% o un alfa
vamos a escribir lo mejor del 0 10
busquemos entonces cuál es el valor
crítico que le corresponde a este alfa a
este nivel de significancia
de 0 a 10 con 2 grados de libertad
busquemos en la tabla de valores sí
que tenemos acá
010 010 está por acá
qué es la probabilidad
y dos grados de libertad y conseguimos
el valor 460
es decir que el valor crítico el valor x
cuadrado el valor cuadrado para una
probabilidad del 10%
con dos grados de libertad es de 460 qué
quiere decir esto
nosotros dijimos que estamos entonces en
esta función con dos grados de libertad
tenemos este valor de acá quiero
marcarlo con un color que se note vamos
a hacer así tenemos dos grados de
libertad esta es la curva que a nosotros
nos compete nosotros sabemos que en 4.60
aproximadamente por acá
aproximadamente por acá vamos a hacerlo
con este color aproximadamente por acá
tenemos 10% de probabilidad 4 coma
coma 60 y nuestro valor crítico era de
253 es decir que estamos aproximadamente
por acá
por lo tanto si recién acá comienza a
ser la probabilidad del 10 por ciento o
si vemos el 10 por ciento del área
cubierta en a partir de este parámetro
en todo este parámetro
tenemos una probabilidad mucho mayor
es decir que la probabilidad de que
ocurra 253 habiendo asumido la hipótesis
nula es mayor al 10% por lo tanto como
es mayor al 10% con este valor no
podemos rechazar
vamos a hacerlo no
podemos
rechazar
la hipótesis nula la hipótesis nula es
decir que no podemos asegurar que las
hierbas hagan algo tengan algún efecto
contra la gripe o el resfrío porque
obtuvimos un valor crítico para los
valores esperados que trabajamos
obtuvimos un valor crítico
mejor dicho este valor crítico que tiene
una probabilidad mayor mucho mayor el
10% y lo podemos ver tranquilamente en
la tabla y en el gráfico